autres cités princières monaco avec le
grand prix de monaco
c'est dimanche c'est l'un des points
forts de la saison automobile en formule
un premier essai cet après-midi
résultats sénat devant prost ça devient
trop habituel mais la lutte entre les
deux hommes devient vous allez devoir de
plus en plus âpre francis maroteaux
depuis le grand prix de san marin une
question fixe l'attention du monde de la
formule 1 alain prost meilleur metteur
au point à l'heure actuelle va-t-il
désormais gardés secrets ses réglages je
préfère fermer jusqu'à las palmas cas je
resterai fidèle à ce que je me suis
toujours fixé à dire d'être honnête dans
une équipe qui paient pour ça je suis
avancé
la partie intégrante de cette équipe qui
va vous pouvez député but depuis 84 qui
a toujours tout fait pour moi et même si
au bout du compte on peut avoir c'est
pas très grave
le ton est donné confirmée ce matin par
ron dennis le patron déclarant que senna
n'avait pas respecté les instructions à
imola pour alain prost est une autre
forme de mise au point importante aussi
mais j'ai surtout par des passionnés
pour un à bestiaux n'est pourtant
mauvais d'avancé à deux choses que je
suppose et verser deux heures cet
après-midi en quatre tours seulement
prost signe le meilleur temps mais ils
cassent le second rapport de boîte dès
lors c'est n'a réussi à nouveau le tour
le plus rapide et c'est mclaren loin
devant encore une fois une seconde et
demie plus vive que les poursuivants
immédiats
mansell woodsen et tarquini à noter
encore le 9e temps de philippe alliot et
le 10e temps d'olivier brouillard